people with personalized number plate
should be banned from
driving easy does anybody in this room
disagree with that full I what what you
yeah
Gladiator oh God exact that that's
that's what I was going
to like that it's real cuz obviously
they want somebody to bring it up in
conversation yeah and it's mortifying
and in think you'd have to apply for it
you'd have to ring someone and be like I
just need personalized number plate yeah
this is a priority in my life yeah yeah
I'm going to call somebody about this
yeah set it up change these ones and
then hopefully register us for the time
that I'm getting into my car that
somebody might go it's not not it's
Sinister it's absolutely Sinister
I it it is though it is it's like a
clown no don't laugh at him he's dead
rice it's not funny no